hello there today I want to give you a
bit of an update on what's going on with
open Assistant about 10 months ago we
launched this initiative to reproduce
chat GPT in the open and to collect all
the data necessary and it's been it's
been a great 10 months so far so where
are we and what's going on I'm not
really good at building up tension or
anything like this so I'll give you the
tldr in the front and then we'll go into
stuff at the end the tldr is we're going
to stop open Assistant we're going to
put a line under it say we're done our
mission is accomplished we've done what
we've set out to do and now it's the
time for other people to continue it has
a bunch of reasons and I know people
will disagree with this some people will
be upset with this people wanted us to
be the open AI the actual open Ai and so
on
um for us it's really good where we are
right now and we don't want this to
become a zombie project that just kind
of carries on forever and and there's
just kind of a brand that at some point
has achieved something great we want
this to be the thing we achieved to be
remembered for that and yeah to say now
it's time for someone else so we'll go
into the individual reasons a little bit
but this is the short of the story now
why have we decided on that when we
started there was nothing there was chat
GPT there was a paper from open AI that
everyone thought could be how chat GPT
was created but there was extremely
little in terms of data especially open
data there was extremely little in terms
of model there was no knowledge around
of how to do how to train these models
well and so on and there was no
infrastructure in place to do any of
that and we came into that and we I want
to say we pave the way in many ways we
have built up a data collection
infrastructure and collected data that
will live forever we have the most
ethical data set on the planet every
single data point was contributed with
full consent and full intent by the
contributors and that's awesome and the
fact that we have achieved that is
absolutely
mind-bogglingly amazing we've also
trained models for sure we've also done
some RL experiments and supervised
fine-tuning and model mixing and even
mixing with synthetic data trying out
all of this
stuff other people are going to train
better models they already have right
people are going to train bigger models
better models people are going to make
prettier chat interfaces than our chat
interface
so all of this was fleeting was
experiment spouse which was cool but
other people are good at it as well what
only we could do was collect the data
and so I'm very proud to say that we
have made the absolute best of that
momentum that existed at that time we
have tried to not waste a single ounce
of human effort in the data collection
and I believe that's what we have
achieved and that's what we want to be
remembered us what people don't realize
is that you know efforts like this
require a lot of work and we are so
grateful for the contributors but we're
also extremely grateful for the
volunteer human moderators that go after
every flagged message that go after
every you know cluster of down votes and
so on uh this is giant amounts of effort
and over time people move on and not
only the moderator move on the
programmers move on and the contributors
move on and we'll just have to recognize
that it was a special time when everyone
was super excited we could all make time
to some degree to come together and
Achieve something that could only be
achieved at that very moment and now
frankly we're overloaded uh many people
are moving on many people don't have
time anymore and of all the people who
complain that things aren moving fast
enough even at this point um you don't
have capacity either so we want we'd
rather want to say okay we've done our
job we've collected the data that data
can be used from now until forever and
we have various confirmations of big
institutions that the data is really
high quality uh so that data set will
live forever and we'd rather say that's
our that's our work product and and yeah
leave it at that now we're obviously
going
to release the data we've gotten so far
and we're also going to try to release a
lot of the chat data especially the ones
with annotations that we've got because
we also know people have put work into
that and we again we don't want to waste
a single amount of of human work that we
don't need to waste so we will release
all of these things um hopefully soon
we'll have to do cleaning and all that
we did for the first data set and then
we also going to uh send some send some
goodies hopefully to the people who are
high on the leaderboard list because
these are like the real heroes is
everyone who contributed code data
moderation and whatnot we want to want
to want to thank the top contributors
there a little bit so if we can find you
if we can you know contact you through
the data that we have on the website
well we'll reach out to you if you're if
you happen to be on top of the
leaderboard uh also our paper got
accepted to the data sets and Benchmark
tracks of NPS and that's also very cool
if you have contributed data and if you
want to be acknowledged uh I invite you
to go to the account section so here you
can click on your name you can go to
your account and then there is a page
that registers your name of you know
being acknowledged in that as well we'll
keep that up to date in the in the
coming um in the coming time so go there
uh tick the check boox and say what you
want to be acknowledged as so lastly
we've turned off the chat interface and
you might have seen that and that's what
probably most people uh noticed first
that the chats don't work anymore the
chats and by the way also the data
collection platform they are they are
distributed systems that are a nightmare
to keep running so these are
these are real systems that run on
Hardware that is faulty people do all
kinds of inputs people bought the things
people abuse it um Hardware fails the
backend workers on the gpus fail and so
on and all of this has to be kept up and
running um redis will overflow all kinds
of things backups need to be made this
all requires active human effort and as
I said we are overloaded and we no
longer have the capacity to do that the
chat system is fully open source you
know you can use it we feel when we
started there was nothing now there is
tons of stuff there are hundreds of
places where you can try out chat models
even our chat models so on on hugging
chat um they they will give you the
opportunity to chat with these things so
it's more accessible than ever we don't
feel it's necessarily our purpose to
provide yet another chat interface
especially if we don't have the capacity
to keep it up on top of that that
interface was actually partially
sponsored by corporate sponsors but also
partially maintained by contributors to
the open Assistant project giving their
personal money into that and you know it
was really good to offer these models
when they first came out because people
wanted to try them out but now there's
so much opportunity everywhere um that's
it's not necessary anymore at least that
is our feeling so we wanted to start a
revolution I think that's what our front
page said and I think that's what we did
we got the open source space or at least
we had a small hand in getting the open
source space the ball rolling uh we
collected data that no one else could
collect that's available now and now the
ecosystem is sprawling and More Alive
than ever and yeah we'll want to hand it
off to other people you
know now in the open source space
there's not just a few hackers around
and a few people doing things there is
there are giant Tech corporations like
meta meddling in the open source space
there are even universities from the
Arab world which are backed by entire
nation states right so to to to sort of
uh trying in the model train space and
so on compete with that is is ridiculous
right as far as the data collection
platform goes as I said this also
requires a lot of human labor to keep it
up and to keep it running and to keep it
moderated and we're looking currently
into maybe giving it up uh for adoption
or something like this but um you know
we'd rather have we'd rather have people
take the code and whatnot and pull pull
up their own thing uh rather you know
because we think there's so much things
to do on that hand I want to Lion has a
few follow-up projects one is called
open empathic uh that deals around data
collection for empathic conversations so
if you want to contribute to that you
can if you want to contribute to
something now that open assistant is
shutting down uh that would be a very
good place so in total
I know it's a bit it's a bit
um we have to say it with like one tear
in an eye but I feel mission
accomplished we have set out to collect
the data necessary to train an open
source chat gbt we have set out to train
these models and to make progress and to
push a revolution in open- Source
instruction models and that's exactly
what we've done and the space is more
alive than ever so we feel we've done
our part and with the help of all of you
which we're extremely extremely thankful
for I hope everyone can let sort of Pat
themselves on the back for this and you
know let's do new things let's do the
next cool thing um let's keep pushing
and let's drive open source forward I
hope this was at least a bit informative
if you're upset I understand um I hope
you can understand a bit from our side I
will be hosting an AMA uh probably next
week on the YouTube channel for everyone
to come and ask their questions about
this and uh you know hopefully uh figure
out how to go forward yeah that's it uh
thank you for contributing and I'll see
you around bye-bye